les 30 Miss France sont enfin dévoilés
qui sont les favoris des chroniqueurs on
a Jérémy
coms je n'exista pas il est là Jérémy
com petit rap Miss-France il est avec
nous juste
après après le sacre d'Indira Enio
l'année dernière à tout juste 18 ans
Miss les Français découvriront le 16
décembre prochain depuis le zénite de
Dijon qui sera la nouvelle Miss France
2024 une 94e édition qui sera présentée
une fois de plus par Jean-Pierre fou
bonsoir et à moins de 2 mois de
l'événement c'est officiel on sait
désormais quels sont les 30 candidates
régionales retenues qui tenteront de
décrocher la prestigieuse couronne des
miss régionales qui se prépareront à
cette élection entre la Bourgogne et la
Guyane alors les 30 Miss enfin dévoilés
qui sont les favoris des chroniqueurs on
en parle ce soir dans
TPMP merci
jéréy Jérémy com regardez cette élégance
regardez C élégance ah ouais c'est non
mais si alors vous êtes coach en bonne
manière de miss-fance et oui ça existe
ça consiste en quoi à accompagner entre
autres les 30u alors aussi j'accompagne
les tempes prétendantes au titre de Miss
France dans les tout ce qui est art de
la table essentiellement mais aussi
prise de parole un peu en public parce
que les miss quand elle enfin il y en a
une qui est là avec nous une ancienne
Miss non est là merci Dani non mais la
veille d'arriver à Paris pour un voyage
qui dure un mois on est encore avec ses
copains et ses copines dans un
restaurant mais quand vous rent quand
elle rentre chez elle un mois après il y
a la miss et les dauphines mais quoi
qu'il arrive vous êtes Miss France dans
votre région et du coup c'est P kebab ou
la créprie entre copains ou là c'est le
c'est le dîner ou le déjeuner avec le
maire le préfet le directeur du du
théâtre local et il y en a beaucoup et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'elles m'ont
surnommé monsieur bonne manière qui
n'ont pas ces codes là et ça quo arrive
ouis ça va mon garsah quand tu pas
l'école parfois et puis surtout elles
sont jeunes elles ont entre 18 ans tu es
encore pour pour certaines au lycées en
première année de d'étude tu es pas
forcément très à l'aise avec une vie
dite mondainne ou sociale cout
exactement ah c'est vrai ou c'est vrai
vous connaissiez vous avez travaillé
avec mais finalement c'est jamais
rencontré non jamais je suis ravi jamais
mais oui oui moi aussi et et c'est vrai
que on est on est on est des bébés en
fait quand on arrive là-bas et on a
l'habitude d'être avec nos potes
effectivement on est des on est des
lycéennes on est des et et ensuite quand
on revient comme vous le dites c'est
c'est vrai on est on côtoie un peu moins
nos amis et puis on avec des chefs
d'entreprise et des choses jamais on
aurait eu accès à ça donc il faut se
mett j'en suis revenu he et les
politiques et tout j'en suis revenu je
Jérémy com coach en bonne manière alors
on va revenir sur les 30 m vous nous
direz donnerez des petit des petites
choses des petits conseils de bonne
manière alors on va démarrer par Miss
Alsace Miss Alsace 2023 c'est Adeline
Vetter c'est ma préférée moi Adeline ver
donc pour vous c'est votre préférée elle
a 27 ans elle fait des études en
pharmacie ça veut dire qu'elle est dans
une pharmacie qu'elle étudie euh voilà
oui al il a quelqu'un qui VI de se
planter
c'est c'est rien c'est un désinvité
c'est rien du tout ça va tout va bien
tombé en bécan c'est le fait mur c'est
le fait mur voir va voir ouis il y a un
mec là qui à mon avis je pense qu'il a
mangé svre entendu un bruit derrière là
le gars à mon avis c'est 30 jours d'
tté là on a entendu il a pris une poise
dans la té j'ai l'impression c'est
explosé le me ouis vraiment là faites
gaffe quand même les mecs allumé les
lumières bordel ça va c'était qui c'est
toi mai c'est pas toi mais tu sais qui
est la personne qui est décédée d'accord
non tu le sais c'est bon elle aelle
d'accord très bien merci t'inquiète
tinquiè voilà donc elle est étudiante en
pharmacie ça veut dire que elle étudie
dans une pharmacie voilà et elle a 27
anselle 27 ans donc heureusement
heureusement que les critères ont changé
parce que sinon on serait passé par
exemple à côté d'une beautée comme ça
exactement exactement elle serait pas
avant ça passait pas 27 bien ça et même
étud en pharmacie ça passait pas non
plus c'est bien que ça connais pas du
coup a un sacré avantage sur celle qu'on
18 ans c'est bien que ça passe non je va
vous dire alors justement on va parler
de missakiten qui elle est très jeune
elle a 19 ans Lola Turpin Lola Turpin la
même euh alors Lola on dirait Britney
Spears en brune la fille de vraiose
ouais elle en licence de marketing ça
veut dire que elle est en licence de
marketing licence c'est 3è année elle a
19 ans ça veut dire que
c'est elle est forte voilà donc elle
aussi si voilà vous allez lui donner des
bonnes manières si vous la vous l'vez
déjà coaché ah non pas du tout je les
découvre pendant le voyage d'intégration
il y a missauverg ensuite 22 ans elle a
une licence aussi de marketing et
également une licence d'échec et de
communication regardez missov c'est
Oriane Maly Oriane my c'est la sœur de
gade g mé euh voilà qu'on embrasse Miss
sovn 2023 c'est pas la favorite de
personne vous découvir à 20h46 on adore
ça découvrir toutes les miss on va
découvrir les 30 Miss on va pas bouder
notre plaisir comme on dit euh y a Miss
Bourgogne et dieu sais que j'aime les
escargots euh oh elle est jolie Luna la
charme elle s'appelle Luna la charme
elle a 18 ans elle est jolie elle est
elle a fait elle est Bachelor Marketing
Communication c'estàd qu'elle elle a
failli faire le le Bachelor euh regardez
elle est ravissante très joli c'est Miss
Bourgogne c'est la favorite de
personnees toujours vous nous dites dès
vous avez favor tell belle Miss Bretagne
Miss Bretagne Noémie le bras 21 ans elle
a un master de gestion de ressources
humaines voilà donc c'est c'est c'est
c'est Noémi ah oui c'est la favoriteé
Noé le BR par comme
ça très joli bragne on embrasse tous les
Bretons d'ailleurs temp est déjà
[Applaudissements]
passé
S
a je vais chercher un truc je vais
chercher un
truc regarde
ça ils sont nul c'est pas sont bêtes
faud leur donner des cours de bonne
manière auss TR franchement elle est
magnifique superbe est super bien sûr
elle a des yeux incroyables une
chevelure Mag le BR gestion de
ressources humaines moi j'en fais
presque ma favorite ah ouais elle est
sublime euh Miss centre valdeoire 2023
ah oui moii glonie giclonou 1,76 ah oui
1,76 22 ans étudiante direction
artistique alors c'est votre favori ah
oui oui moi j'adore
l'artistique Émilie giclon Miss
valdeloir mal magnifique bravo donc
c'est la favorite de Guillaume pour
l'instant on a eu la favorite de
Delphine la favorite de Guillaume et
c'est tout Miss champagne hardarden no
du titre 21 ans étudiant en langue
é ah oui alors c'est la favorite de
qui de vous je suis allé voir sur son
son sa page Instagram oui journaliste
d'investigation
commence elle prend très très bien la
lumière non franchement beaucoup très
bien la lumière toi depuis que tu es ici
tu prends très
bien alors les chiries j'ai convaincu
Jean-Michel miss Corse magnifique
sraabac master dans l'enseignement alors
imaginez si vous avez une professeur
comme ça vous
direz magnif je redouble tous les ans je
vois pas moi Miss cor donc Sandra bac on
a Miss cô d'Azur
carlaité parce qu'elle est trs on peut
changer ou
pas oh s'il vous plaît calmez-vous non
non mais on en choisit qu'une s'il vous
plaît on n pas chez vos mères j' a chois
plein Carla B j'en ai pris plein moi moi
j'ai pris Carla elle me dira 75 elle est
magnifique ouais Carla Béchir euh 19 ans
mannequin très très jolie très jolie
c'est pas mon délire mais très jolie
Sonia Couton euh Miss franche compé 2023
elle est être soignante en épad jolie à
mon avis ça doit revigorer les les
personnes tu meurs
pas mais là là je peux vous dire quand
vous amenez votre grand-père en
épade rester t'emmerde pas je rester
papi je vais tenir t'emmerde pas non
t'inquiète pas t'emmerde pas reviens
demain reviens pas ah alors e très très
jolie Miss Guadeloupe 2023 jalilan ma 18
ans ah ouiès belle très belle elle a
quelque chose ou elle a un truc le
sourire très très beau sourire elle est
en licence administrative économique et
sociale il y a pas une chôeuse il
a pas une chuse il y a pas une chôuse il
y a miss guyan qui s'appelle Audrey
owensai 18 ans elle veut devenir agent
dans le marketing tu très jeune c'est
vraiment la plus elle fait très très
jeune ou Missile de France
2 elle est consultante en
cybécurité écoutez là je pense que là
c'est important de consul c'est
important de sécuriser tout ça la mi
c'est la mien
francera vous m'ave demandé de chois
c'est ta
favorite lui regardez-moi ce char il a
pris missile de France pour pas se
déplacer il s dit qu'il pit aller en
camion j'en
V une horreur elle a 28
ansenardz 1,13 1,73 donc c'est très bien
bien pour vous ça Miss long dog 2023
Maxime Tessier Maxime Tessier souhaite
devenir vétérinaire chirurgical à la 19
ans Maxime très jeune Miss lmousin il y
a Agathe toulieu 21 ans étudiante en
école de commerce regardez Agathe
toulieu Miss Loren 2023 c'est Angélique
Aaron close 26 ans aut entrepreneuse
dans le maquillage ah change un Zaz on
dirait Zaz sur la photo de droite
nonentre audreé flur audre FL
également ma mère aussi bon c'est
bon Miss Martinique Chloé Modestine 21
ans elle est en BTS Commerce
International ça veut dire que voilà
elle fait du commerce international elle
a des beau ye Miss Mayot ah je l'aime
bien aussi udaifa shibaco 21 ans
étudiante en psychologie très joli 1 M72
1,72 c'est ma favorite ouais merci elle
va gagner elle va gagner ah ouais benah
écoute elle est magnifique puis pour son
petit village et pour toutes les femmes
maorises ce serait formidable pour Mayot
ce serait extraordinaire donc c'est ta
favorite mon Gil c'est très bien Miss
midi pyrené Nadine Benabou elle est
bellead 22 ans chargé de clot elle est
chargée de clot dans une concession
automobile ah j'adore les bagnolesore
les bagnoles
elle est très belle je trouve
nadinead Benabou elle un N bien
Miss 20 ans licence de
mathématiqueose Mor
21s 21 école de commerce ouais très
beaux yeux elle a des beaux yeux Miss
Pays de la Loire Clémence Ménard 25 ans
elle est infirmière ah non dire quand
faire une opération il y a Clémence qui
arrive dans la chambre quiard ah Miss
Picardy c'est Charlotte crisson 23 ans
elle est
opticienne voilà y a Miss poitoucharante
c'est moi louness Texier 18 ans c'est
votre favorite fa elle est étudiante en
art et spectacle c'est d'abord c'est
Royant c'est la région de Royant mais
surtout elle elle est fraîche je trouve
qu'elle est pluselle elle fait elle fait
moins m que les autres je trouve ouais
c'est vrai c'est
fou non mais pour dire qu'elles sont
formatées moi j'en ai marre de tout ta
pas demandé ton sont pas formaté mais
c'est vrai rigoler so ça c'est comme si
un mec qui a pas le permis qui va donner
son avis sur comment conduire un mais
moi je suis téléspectatrice adlina blanc
25 ans est dentiste regardez
apparemment ouis je pense qu'elle va oh
ah oui est spectaculaire Miss Réunion
Mélanie odules 21 20 ans elle est
conseillère de vente elle est très jolie
miss ronalp alisé Bidau c'est la mienne
22 ans c'est c'est se de person elle est
soigneuse anim c'est votre favorite ta
favorite c'est votre favorite ouiais
bien c'est ma favorite Miss Roussillon
ellise
akidina 22 ans elle a un master de droit
public général sont tout brillant et
enfin mux Miss tahi ravaer Siou 25 ans
Master Marketing Digital on va revoir
les favorites de chacun chéri à 20h54 en
direct pour Jean-Michel c'est donc
ronalp ronalp s'il vous plaît c'est donc
alis bid alis bid Gilles c'est
Maillotte Maillotte pour
Gill pour Daniel c'est le poidouche
charante
est mign pour Valérie non mais on
pourrait pas en prendre deux ça sera
centreval de Loire mais j'avais dit midi
pyéné c'est midi pyen alors vous me
faites
PIR Géraldine ou Côte d'Azur et Nord
pcalé Carla ah tu avais dit de aussi dro
C d'AZ non a pris Côte d'Azur je pr c
d'Azur Côte d'Azur Jacques champagne
Arden champagne Arden il a même été voir
son insta pour vous dire le
professionnalisme conscieux
Guillaume centrev de Loire je fais des
gros
bisous vous dégû elle revient deux fois
du
coup on dirait qu'il suffoque c'est
insupportable Delphine vous avez pris
l'Alsace
oui elle est belle et Raymon île-defance
Picardie
mid
merci merci merci Jérémie est votre
favorite est-ce que vous avez le droit
de le dire non je peux pas vous donner
le nom de ma favorite en revanche il y a
quelque chose qui est sûr c'est que vos
choix aujourd'hui sont sans doute pas
les mêmes après le mois qu'elle passe ah
c'est ça parce que il y a aussi des
personnalités il y a des jeunes femmes
et des jeunes filles qui arrivent on se
dit et ell se dévoileent au fur et à
mesure elles prennent de la place elles
ont du charisme de la posture mange
beaucoup je voulais pas parler de ça
mais et c'est très surprenant en
revanche il y a aussi ça moi il y a deux
miss par exemple Dian qui qui est parti
aujourd'hui à New York pour Miss Univers
et Amandine petit dans l'avion le
premier jour je savais qu'elle serait
Miss France les deux vraiment par que
elle dégageait un charisme que les
autres n'avaient pas quand en fin de
compte il faut une une personnalité qui
quand elle entre dans une pièce les
regards se détournent non mais
franchement tu
rentr
regard oui céit on le voit pendant le
voyage parce qu'on est souvent dans des
hôtels où il y a du des des vacanciers
des touristes il a y a des jeunes filles
dont vraiment elles ont l'approbation du
de leur premier public et elles font
toute la différence et pour peu qu'elles
soit drôle et intelligente ce qui est
souvent le cas quand
même c'est pas aussi simple que de que
sur des photos très posé quand même
elles ont tout pour ell merci en tout
cas Jérémy et tu reviendras nous voir
quand tu veux avec Jo nous donner des
conseils de bonne manière serait sympa
vendredie pour nous redonner des
conseils de bonne manière ça serait pas
mal hein voilà comment péter en toute
liberté ça je vous laisse merci merci on
va parler euh d'un sujet une